نريد بلدًا يمكننا العيش فيه ، لقد
مرت 16 عامًا ، صرخ هذا الشاب أنني
خريج جامعي
ليس لديه عمل.
العمل الوحيد الذي وجده هو في
صالون لتصفيف الشعر يقول إنه كان
يتظاهر منذ أيام ، وهم يصرخون على
بعضهم البعض حول استخدام الحكومة
للقوة لأصدقائهم الذين قُتلوا
في المظاهرات ، والظلم الذي قام به هذا
الرجل الذي لا يريد
الكشف عن هويته هو التصوير.  منذ
البداية ، لا يوجد شيء
يعتقد أن الناس لم يهاجموا أن
سلاحنا الوحيد
كان قطع الطريق جسديًا حتى
لا تتمكن قوات الأمن من
المضي قدمًا في مطالب المتظاهرين.
التوظيف وتحسين الخدمات الأساسية ،
لكن الاحتجاجات أصبحت
أكثر عنفًا ، مما يهدد
الأمن الهش بالفعل في هذا البلد ويؤدي إلى ارتفاع معدل
الوفيات  أثارت حصيلة الضحايا حفيظة أولئك الذين يحاولون
النزول إلى الشوارع